in einem der letzten videos habe ich
mich innerhalb von fünf tagen mit einem
euro so lang hoch gehandelt wird sich
den flug noch mal lehrerzahlen kommt
allerdings kamen mir die frage auf was
wohl wäre wenn man keine fünf tage zeit
hat und auch den staat euro nicht hätte
viel spaß mit wie schwer ist es für 0
euro in den urlaub zu fahren
[Musik]
nun ja wir könnten fahrrad fahren wir
könnten laufen und allgemein sollte
bekannt sein dass es auch mit dem
longboard möglich wäre all diese
optionen sind aber ziemlich
zeitaufwendig und man ist definitiv
länger als einen tag unterwegs also
bleibt weil wir natürlich auf illegale
sachen die schwarzfahren verzichten
wollen nur noch das trampen so das
wichtigste zum trampen sind vermutlich
die route und das schild die rede so als
hätte ich ahnung davon ich habe das
selber noch nie gemacht das schild habe
ich jetzt aus dem müll und karton
ausgekannt und da werde ich jetzt
einfach amsterdam draufschreiben und
gute habe ich natürlich einfach über
google maps rausgefunden
wieso tust du das ich bin auf dem weg
zur autobahn 57 als allererstes
vielleicht finden wir direkt jemanden
der uns ein paar meter mitnehmen kann
aber als allererstes muss das team bei
gw an ohne zu sterben
da es geht wirklich los macht es
wirklich
ein kleines aber feines problem die
autobahn auf wie ich möchte hat keinen
standstreifen
ich laufe jetzt erstmal entlang bis ich
irgendwas finde wo auch autos anhalten
können um nicht mitzunehmen erste
erfahrungen mit dem trampen muss
definitiv bereit sein manchmal ein
bisschen fußweg auf sich zu nehmen
glaube ich zumindest muss ich das jetzt
weil ich nicht vernünftig geplant habe
vorne ist die 750 da muss sich drauf und
hier ist die auffahrt das bedeutet das
laufen hat sich gelohnt und ich stelle
mich jetzt hier vorne hin wohl mein
schild raus zu den daumen raus und dann
finden wir hoffentlich jemanden der und
widme mich mitnimmt packen nicht direkt
dass amsterdams schild aus ich glaube
das schreckt ein paar leute vielleicht
ab wo wir jetzt erstmal auf der 750 ein
bisschen weiter hoch zu kommen
mal schauen ob es funktioniert und dann
begann das warten ist es so fucking
betont die zeit verging und verging
alle leute die vorbeifahren gucken
gefühlt so ein bisschen wie schwebend
weg dass sie eigentlich mitnehmen was
geht mich werdet ihr immer sehen wenn im
video viel zu wenig passiert ist und ich
irgendwelche sehen fühlen muss bisher
ist nichts passiert außer dass mich ein
paar leute angeguckt haben und so ein
bisschen überlegt haben aber nach wie
vor stehe ich hier und halte manchen
innerhalb von zwei minuten habe ich
gerade zwei reactions bekommen eine
person hat sich entschuldigt dass sie
keine zeit hatte um die andere hat mich
ausgelacht
die ersten 45 minuten sind um keine
anstalten gemacht mich mitzunehmen das
wird noch spaß wechsel jetzt noch mal
die position gehen nochmal 100 meter
weiter nach vorne da ist eine ampel und
vielleicht dann wird auch noch ein
bisschen mehr
vielleicht haben wir da überhaupt mal
ein bisschen glück haben wir nicht
gerade haben sich schon wieder leute
entschuldigt finde ich super nett weil
der andere richtung gefahren sind aber
naja zu diesem zeitpunkt waren bereits
drei stunden vergangen wechselt jetzt
einmal komplett die strategie und den
ort also nicht nur so 150 meter weiter
die straße hoch sondern ich wechsele die
autobahn ich gehe auf die a3 und ich
glaube dass da noch ein paar mehr leute
nach amsterdam fahren und da vielleicht
gegen jemand dabei ist er gewillt ist
mich mitzunehmen
also erstmal in die straßenbahn ab
richtung a3 und dann geht es weiter
du hast gesagt kostenlos und jetzt fest
die bahn ja ich fahre kostenlos bauen
das ist die auffahrt zur a 3 auf der ich
jetzt hoffentlich jemanden finden der
mich mit nach amsterdam nimmt ich werde
mich jetzt da unten hin stellen mein
schild auspacken
und warten ich habe das gefühl das war
eine sehr schlechte entscheidung hin zu
gehen
ja
ja muss ich zugeben war nicht die
schlaueste position dem angerufen dass
er die polizei ruft aber ich bin
natürlich schon weg
flaute fahrrad mir gerade einen tipp
gegeben dass ich mich woanders
hinstellen soll wo öfter tramper stehen
das werde ich jetzt tun und dann mal
sehen
dann kommt sie wieder zu einer meiner
lieblings situation ich filme den ganzen
tag dann passiert das was ich die ganze
zeit probiere zu filmen und die kamera
ist zum ersten mal aus perfekt so
freundes hat wirklich geklappt hat
angehalten wenn er jetzt noch bereit ist
mit mir vor der kamera während der fahrt
zu reden dann ist alles perfekt
vier autostunden später befinde ich mich
in amsterdam
die beiden waren super sympathisch
wollten leider nicht gefilmt werden war
aber einen super entspannter autofahrt
wir haben noch pizza gegessen und jetzt
sind wir in amsterdam
also einen tag aufwand zum ersten mal
trennten ich habe sehr viel falsch
gemacht aber anscheinend auch ein
bisschen was richtig denn ich bin
angekommen ich glaube jetzt ein bisschen
hier durch die stadt habe auf instagram
gerade jemanden gefunden bei dem ich
kostenlos übernachten kann mégane eis
und ich habe jetzt direkt den live
stream an damit der tägliche live stream
nicht abbricht und die ganzen leute auch
noch was von mir live mitbekommen so
schnell noch mal ein paar abschließende
worte also im endeffekt war es echt mega
anstrengend ich stand sechs stunden
draußen und habe wirklich in den letzten
paar minuten als sich wer nach hause
gegangen wenn der jetzt nicht in fünf
minuten gekommen da jemand gekommen wäre
er mich mitgenommen hätte dann bin ich
halt super später in amsterdam gekommen
hatte aber glück dass niklas den ich
noch nie getroffen habe mir einen
schlafplatz gegeben hat und ich glaube
das war im endeffekt auch mein highlight
also dass sich niklas kennengelernt habe
und nicht das trennt man sich das war
nämlich gar nicht so aufregend wie ich
gedacht habe sondern eher ziemlich
langweilig weil ich sechs stunden lang
draußen stand noch mal würde ich das
vermutlich nicht machen wenn es nur ein
tagestrip oder so geht wenn es aber in
der kompletten reise nur ums trennten
geht und man irgendwie weiter weg fahren
möchte ist es ziemlich heiß und ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass im sommer mal
ein bisschen länger zu machen doch was
hat euch gefallen wenn ja lassen leicht
und so da macht's gut
und dann guckt euch das an